fait des araignées des désertions et
c'est avec de l'argile les petites bêtes
ont envahi la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt ont fêté la nature et la forêt
le thème du 8e festival courants d'art
l'idée c'est avec les enfants de
réaliser tous ces animaux en argile ou
avec des éléments qu ont accueilli ce
matin avec les enfants pour voilà créer
ces petites bêtes on s'est rendu compte
que c'était vraiment un sujet
d'actualité qu'en termes scientifiques
il y avait beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes mais aussi en termes
poétiques
la forêt c'est un c'est un lieu de
l'imaginaire c'est c'est le lieu du
grand méchant loup de l'ogre de la belle
au bois dormant et c'est un lieu
voilà qui parle à toutes les générations
des ateliers de création des expositions
et des performances
le festival est organisé tous les deux
ans par les écoles de la ville
elle prépare et créé en commun l'idée
c'est vraiment le travail
transdisciplinaire c'est à dire faire se
rencontrer les disciplines et faire
pratiquer ensemble des gens issus de
disciplines différentes c'est proposer
aux danseurs de pratiquer les arts
plastiques s'est proposé aux plasticiens
de découvrir la danse
pour cette huitième édition une
plasticienne un chorégraphe et les
itinéraires poétiques ont été associés